This video is sponsored by BOOK WALKER
What are you doing step bro?
Since the beginning of mankind we have always been drawn to fire.
It's mesmerizing flames
dancing and weaving was what kept us alive and warm
allowed us to cook food for more nutritional meals
that helped us to develop our evolving brains.
Which is why in the modern age almost as if by instinct we are still drawn to
a dumpster fire no matter how dangerous or smelly or...
...incestuous it may be.
Domestic girlfriend or to go by its Japanese name
Domestic na Kanojo
or Kokunai no girlfriend
or BOKU NO GIRLFRIEND ACADEMIA
is the latest romance to spice up this anime community.
A full-on 4K 60 Frames-per-second
car crash in slow motion that explodes into a
beautiful roaring "did not related by blood" flame
that we as dumpster moths can't help but fly into.
So if you're feeling happy cuz Kaguya-sama
has finally cured your depression this season have no fear.
Domestic girlfriend has come along just in time to bring it back again.
See, this show isn't just any romance anime,
This is THE NEXT LEVEL of romance anime.
You know how in most anime romances it takes
ten decades of character standing around wondering if they should confess?
And then when we finally get some hot steamy hand-holding action
they get cock-blocked once again by everyone's favorite third wheel...
...Fireworks-kun.
Yeah, that's right I'm calling you out!
Do you know how many fucking confessions you've ruined?
Well, luckily domestic girlfriend is so much more realistic
because it starts with a dude having just smashed a bird.
Oh, and that dude's got a crush on his teacher.
Oh and his dad's getting remarried.
Oh, and his new stepsisters are gonna be his teacher and the girl he lost his virginity to.
Oh, and they're gonna be living in the same house and starting a step-sibling love triangle
[slurp]
[cough]
Spicy, very spicy
Now you may be sitting here thinking
"Wow this sounds like it can only end badly" but
I can assure you despite what sounds like an absolute disaster of a premise...
[crash, horse scream]
...it only goes downhill from here
See when talking about domestic girlfriend
we have to describe things in terms of spice level
because literally every episode something happens that will give you the uncontrollable urge to go
WOOH-HOOHOOHOO!
That's a spicy boy!
Step-sibling crushes,
teacher-student relationships,
affairs with married men,
love pentagrams,
...love rivals. What's next?
Find out on the next episode of "Two Girls, One Brother"
[He-he boy!]
But don't worry, it's not some creepy siscon kind of show, you know, I swear I swear to god
I mean, we all know it's not incest
anyway, if you shout NO CHROMO.
If we take a look at some of the spiciest peppers in the world we have
the famous ghost pepper at around a million scovilles,
the Trinidad scorpion which beats even that,
and the granddaddy the Carolina Reaper at a whopping
2.2 million Scoville units
a pepper so spicy that it's even hospitalized some people for eating it and yet
that is nothing compared to...
getting rejected by your first love and almost double suiciding with her
who's also your teacher stepsister,
making out with your other stepsister,
flirting with your club president only to then walk in on your teacher stepsister
buttering her muffin to the thoughts of her ex-lover
while you just stand there and watch while emotional j-pop plays
In the span of a single episode it was, it was... [laughing]
IT WAS A SINGLE FUCKING EPISODE, WOOH, WOOH!
CAN I GET SOME MILK TO WASH THIS SPICE OFF?
Now I know what you're thinking: "oh look Giggik's talking about another trashy sister show
does he want this to be the new Eromanga Sensei or something?
HOO-HOO-HOO-HOO
and I take offense to that because it should be obvious that these two shows are nothing alike
I mean I might have called them both trash but one is a flaming dumpster and the other...
...is a flaming dumpster...
that the UN definitely wanna ban.
Not to mention if you compare the two protagonists you got the virgin Masamune
fantasizing over a single week source of a little sister who'd probably
spontaneously combust withour constant care and attention so he has to play man slave
and here we got Natsuo
already got laid
fuckin dual-wielding incest at this point
while juggling other girls
reaching levels of Chad never before thought possible
And this isn't even mentioning the girls
because what I can respect to someone who knows what they want and they fucking go for it.
Cuz if you're an anime girl
and someone tells you that you can't be with the protagonist because of some bizarre reason like
[chuckle]
Your family or something.
You just need to hit them with one of these
[Persona All-Out-Attack SFX]
Yes this time we've got THE sister,
the sister who's also your teacher,
the shy club president,
and a girl who's glops enough semen to put her into
clinical depression.
I'm just kidding Momo is a fucking angel
and deserves with a love care and attention and semen she wants
Now I know I said before that nothing could compete with Hina
as the older stepsister that's also your teacher.
But in my calculations I forgot just how much Rui can tip the scale because you see in life
there are these mythical creatures that we cannot confirm the existence of
and Rui is one of those creatures of
legend the sacred being we know only as...
The Imouto
Plus she's a short blue haired anime waifu.
So I'm feeling pretty hopeful for her chances because of all the other short
blue haired anime waifus who got to live happily ever after with the person they love like...
[aaaah...]
So yeah, I'm feeling quite hopeful!
Then the thing about this show is that no matter how much destruction and disaster was happening on-screen
I couldn't peel my eyes away from it.
And you gotta admit you're morbidly curious, too aren't you?
Watching domestic girlfriend is like building a death coaster in roller coaster tycoon
then letting people on the ride to see what happens next.
You know the roller coaster is gonna fly off into a crowd of people
causing massive destruction because that's the way you built it.
You know, it's gonna happen, but you watch anyway because [indistinguishable mumbling]
And see I feel like there's a secret to the spicy formula that is domestic girlfriend, and that's...
HENTAI
[awkward pause]
All right hear me out.
It is quite well documented that hentai is an art form that rivals the likes of
Picasso
Andy Warhol
And that toothbrush scene in Nisemonogatari.
But you must remember that it runs on its own rules not bound by the laws of reality
where fat ugly businessmen are the model of peak masculinity
and hips are sentient beings that can move on their own.
Because that world isn't the same 2019 world we live in now.
I bet they don't even ask the like button for consent
before smashing it.
So when watching an episode of Domestic Girlfriend
you may wonder how they can pack so much spice into every episode.
But once you realize it runs on hentai rules, it makes perfect sense.
We've got levels of cocking-not-seeing since Netorare Genesis Gurrengellion.
We've got people who are allergic to closing doors because you can't spell SPICY without SPY.
We've got every conceivable vanilla hentai setup you can ask for.
The older sister is having a beer?
How long till she passes out on the sofa and the guy tries kissing her?..
Two minutes. Jesus it was literally two minutes.
[OOH]
We couldn't make this more hentai if we tried!
[Natsuo gasps]
What are you doing stepbr-
That brings up an important question
Why would I want to watch a hentai without the banging in it?
Doesn't that defeat the entire point?
I can't jack off to this!
And that's a very good question and I think the only proper response is...
Bro, if you set your mind to it, you can jack off to anything [PEEP]
See, the advantage of going by hentai rules
is that it allows your series to become... [horny smile]
"plot heavy"
Because in this art form it needs to be
"plot heavy" [horny smile]
because you don't want to waste precious time with people not banging
so you constantly need spicy things to be happening and surprisingly
that's entertaining as fuck!
Cuz why would you want to watch some vanilla sex scene anyway
when you could just see characters get goldenshowered with depression.
And this leads me to believe that the unreleased full title of the show
is actually domestic na kanojo x kanojo x kanojo
Don't look at me like that, I know you got that reference.
In case you are under the age of 7 and have never visited a Adult site, that clever reference was towards the eroge novel called Kanojo x Kanojo x Kanojo. (roughly translating to Girlfriend x Girlfriend x Girlfriend) It's rather famous for having the most liked OVA (Original Video Animation) on Hentai Haven and selling well when it was first released as a visual novel. Now then if this makes it into the video, why did you pause the video to read this? Come on man, there's a good solid four minutes left to this video.
Of course with all the spiciness I witness in the runtime of the show
it made me morbidly curious to see how big of a car crash the manga would be.
And what I found was my absolute worst fear...
[sigh]
...that I did I really fucking enjoyed it.
[taps on the table]
All right, just let me explain
While the start of the series is a spicy mess as it moves on
adequate time is given to really flesh out the characters and make them relatable.
Even some characters who I wasn't a fan of initially won me over and before you know it you're... invested.
Despite all the semen demons vying for a taste of Natsuo's seed
no one ever acts in a way that's completely inconsiderate or douchey.
Everyone's just been put in a fucked up situation and they're trying their best
to handle these messy feelings that they know they probably shouldn't have.
For example for the full-on School Days disaster route this could go
Natsuo never goes out of his way just to get his dick wet every time a girl opens her Gate of Babylon for him.
He genuinely cares about everyone around him and acts in a way that tries to make everyone happy.
So it's hard to hate him because despite how fucking stupid and naive his actions can be
you want everyone to be happy, too
but you also know that because of the way things are set up that's impossible.
Someone or everyone is gonna end up with their heart broken. So it's less of a case of...
WHY THE HELL ARE YOU DOING THIS YOU STUPID IDIOTS?!
and more of
GODDAMIT' I KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO HAPPEN BUT IT DOESN'T HURT ANY LESS
Combine this with the same spicy plot progression that will continue to make you shout
[HOOH! HOOH!]
every few chapters and you have yourself a really compelling read.
Things continually happen, even if you know
it's all just melodramatic junk food shit,
but you're invested enough in the characters to keep you turning the next page.
Unlike your normal Harem romance where you have 200 chapters of
"Will they? Won't they? No they will. No they won't"
OK, can something just happen can please something happen
PLEASE JUST SOMETHING HAPPEN.
And then just as you're about to give up all hope
they finally confess and maybe kiss and then the show just ends.
[AHEM]
Nothing in Domestic Girlfriend is ever static.
Time actually progresses at a reasonable pace
and you see characters going through different stages of their lives.
Without spoiling anything that happens the plot eventually moves
past everyone being in high school.
You get to see how characters tackle relationships
when they have things like job aspirations college
and responsibilities to worry about.
Characters face repercussions for the actions they take and they learn and change from it.
Action never comes without consequence
and oh boy is there a lot of fuckin' action!
So even though when reading a normal anime romance, your emotional states may go something like this
oooh, they gonna get together, nooooo, ok, noooooOOO, OK OH, i'm up, i'm happy
Domestic girlfriend is more like...
[AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA]
To me domestic girlfriend is the perfect melodrama
blending human characters who develop over the course of the story
with some of the most ridiculous plot progression that is undeniably melodrama trash
but you want to know what happens next cuz you're invested in the characters.
Which leads me to believe this may actually be
a good manga with trashy moments in it...
...or a trashy manga with good moments and
I-I-I haven't quite figured out which way around it is yet.
While, I initially read ahead just to see how trashy it became
I ended up marathoning the entire series in two days.
So even though I came in was the complete intention of memeing the fuck out of everything
It's become my newest obsession that I can't recommend enough.
So if you want a really addicting drama to read
go pick this up and if you need any more reason
unlike the anime the manga has got
FUKKIN' TITTIES
Hey, also, you didn't hear this from me but there are these things called .5 chapters
which aren't necessarily there to move the plot along but I think they're worth reading anyway
because you might find something that'll take the manga to what we'll call...
[inhales]
PEAK SPICE
[SEX SEX SEX]
I'm neither team Hina or Team Rui. At this point I just want both to be happy
[GIGGUK HAVE LEFT US A CLUE BY TYPING TEAM RUI FROM A CAPITAL LETTER, SWEEET]
Hey guys, hope you enjoyed that video. Thank you very much to BOOK WALKER for sponsoring this video.
I didn't have an official sponsorship with them scheduled this month, but I was like
Look, I'm making a Domestic Girlfriend video whether you want to be involved or not
because there's no way I'm not gonna talk about this series.
You can get all of the Domestic Girlfriend volumes available on Book Walker
in the link below and they are even doing this as the simulpubs so you can get all of the new chapters
as they come out in Japan.
Just make sure you search for the Domestic Girlfriend Serial in the search bar if you want the simulpub chapters
and as always new users can use coupon code GIGGUK for five dollars off
just the fair warning though guys if you do pick up this manga
don't expect to stop until you've completely caught up and feel the void of having no new chapters to read
because holy crap, is this an addicting read.
There. I've warned you don't come crying to me when that feeling of complete emptiness hits you once you've caught up
You know what I'm saying, right manga reader [HELL YES WE DO!].
Anyway, that's it for me. I've been Gigguk and I'll see you all next time